Die MS Europa 2:
bei Weitem nicht das größte,
wohl aber eines der luxuriösesten
Kreuzfahrtschiffe der Welt.
Wo immer der Luxusliner auftaucht,
ist ihm Aufmerksamkeit gewiss –
so wie hier bei einer
Veranstaltung im Hamburger Hafen.
Das ganze Jahr über ist die
MS Europa 2 unterwegs:
von der Ostsee-Kreuzfahrt bis
zur mehrwöchigen Atlantik-Reise.
Vor jeder neuen Tour überprüft
Hotelmanager Johann Schrempf,
ob alles seine Ordnung hat.
Der Österreicher ist Chef von 280
der insgesamt 370 Besatzungsmitglieder.
Auf „seinem“ Schiff soll es
nicht nur luxuriös,
sondern vor allem auch
entspannt zugehen.
Bei uns gibt es nicht mehr
dieses klassische Kapitänsdinner,
wie man es sonst gewohnt ist,
oder den Empfang,
sondern bei uns ist das eher etwas
legerer – auch von der Kleiderordnung her.
516 Passagiere haben auf
der MS Europa sehr viel Platz,
denn sie wohnen
ausschließlich in Suiten.
Die beiden größten sind
mit je 114 Quadratmetern
die sogenannten „Owner-Suiten“.
Der Preis wird nur
auf Anfrage genannt.
Die Größenordnung: etwa
zweieinhalbtausend Euro – pro Tag.
Am liebsten schaut
der Hotelmanager
vor der Abfahrt noch einmal
selbst nach dem Rechten.
Diese Ein- und Ausschiffungen,
was [die] bei uns relativ schnell
und unter Druck passieren müssen,
da kann sein, dass man
mal etwas übersieht.
Dadurch geh ich dann noch mal und
schaue gerade in gewissen Segmenten,
ob das dann auch seine
Richtigkeit hat oder nicht.
Farbakzente finden sich nur sparsam
in den dezent gehaltenen Suiten.
Die Hamburger Architekten Kai Bunge
und Siegfried Schindler
haben das komplette Innere
des Schiffes gestaltet.
Ihnen ist wichtig, dass alles auch so
aussieht, wie sie es vorgegeben haben.
Das geht wirklich bis ins kleinste Detail.
Muss!
Muss! Ja.
Muss.
Und das spürt der Passagier, wenn er
vielleicht auch letzten Endes
nicht jedes einzelne Detail
hundertprozentig wahrnimmt,
direkt wahrnimmt, aber er ...
Er spürt es!
… empfindet die Gesamtkomposition,
wenn die stimmig ist.
Kein Luxus-Schiff ohne Spa-Bereich.
Auch dieser ist in seinen Farben auf die
Ausstattung des Schiffes abgestimmt
und bietet viel Platz, innen und außen.
Das Deck vier ist der
sogenannte öffentliche Bereich.
Hier gibt es acht Restaurants,
Bars, einen Jazzclub
und ein Theater mit 418 Plätzen.
Letzte Vorbereitungen
auch unter Deck:
Das Team bekocht die Gäste mit
internationalen Spezialitäten,
etwa aus der italienischen,
französischen oder japanischen Küche.
Zeit für eine kleine Pause für
Hotelmanager Johann Schrempf.
So irgendwie hat mir meine
Mutter das mitgegeben:
Ich komm immer zur richtigen
Zeit am [an den] richtigen Ort.
Und dann geht es los.
Die nächsten Ziele der MS Europa 2:
Skandinavien, Südeuropa, die
amerikanische Ostküste und die Karibik.